[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studios this is the
ramsey show where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money in your marriage whatever is
going on in your life we're here for you
call is free and that's about how much
the advice is worth at triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john dolonie joined here by george
campbell and we're pumped right so
pumped cannot wait between the two of us
we've got two phds so we should be able
to get through these calls today john
thanks for carrying the load for us i
had a joke that i didn't even repeat
right there that's that's me getting why
uh uh getting mature right in front of
you i've learned how you deal with the
bullies is you get there first oh i see
what you did yeah that's it's a defense
mechanism no absolutely you're my
therapist now thanks john all right
let's go to esther in las vegas what's
up esther
hi how's it going good you
i'm doing great thanks for taking my
call today absolutely what's up
so my question is um i don't know if my
side business is worth it
um it seems to be really stressful and i
don't know if it's really helping or
hurting my family um why did you start
the side business
i actually started it because chrissy
wright inspired me back in 2020 and
i had been a photographer like a
hobbyist photographer for
15 plus years and i thought why not just
go for it i can make some more money for
my family
and it kind of helped pay some you know
bills and it's my passion so
i went for it and yeah tell me what's
happening in your family now
oh my family's great um i do have i have
three kids uh the oldest is 14 i have a
12 year old and a seven-year-old
and um they're all going to different
schools this year and there's just a lot
on my plate so
i don't know
if keeping my business going is worth it
right now or
it's just kind of too much here's the
here's the
question
are you tired and you want to stop
and you don't have an exit strategy here
or you'll feel like a failure you'll be
covered up in shame that's one thing
you're just tired you don't do this job
anymore
and for some reason you don't trust
yourself enough to give yourself
permission to just stop
the other
is
your family's falling apart balls are
getting dropped you and your husband's
marriage is getting messy you're not
showing up to things because you're late
running around like there's chaos that
the job is directly contributing to and
maybe it's a little bit of both but i'm
listening to you talk and it sounds like
things are good
you're just tired and you'd rather focus
on things like school and things and so
what prohibits you from just saying i'm
gonna wrap this sucker up
well i feel like
um
i just put myself so much out there to
start my business
and i'm in a small town so i'm getting
a lot of attention now people know me
pretty well um i should probably tell
you guys i work with
senior and teen high school students
okay so i work with um girls i have like
a senior nt
team so i work with them all year i
photograph them all year
and so i feel like
i'm just going to be a failure if i quit
and it's kind of going to be an
embarrassing moment um where does that
story come from
a that you're a failure b that
quitting is forever all or nothing see
that focusing on your three kids and
your marriage and your home
is less important than having people in
your community like think weird things
about you
where those stories come from because
none of them are true
where they come from
i i do not know
i think another big part of it is
i had there was another photographer in
my um town who was doing what i was
doing
and she kind of came out she was kind of
giving it up and moving to a different
career and she kind of came out and said
hey i'm giving this up but tara is
taking kind of taking over for me that's
there you have out esther sorry you have
outsourced
all
of your personal thoughts and feelings
to others
and until you take ownership of that you
are going to be a kite in the wind
being blown around by politicians and
friends and a
somebody who used to have a small
business a long time ago in your same
town
is is dictating you taking care of your
kids in the way that you feel like you
should um i
i don't know what more to say other than
they don't get a vote
the person who gets a vote is you and
your husband and that's about it maybe
one or two close friends that's about it
and then you make the choice to do
what's best for family yeah i'm just
putting pause on this i think in your
mind it's this is forever yeah i'm gonna
let the whole entire community down i'm
too famous to stop and you can just go
you know what i did it for a season it's
photography still a passion of mine but
for right now this is what's important
and george you and i like
this isn't us being like oh shock self
like
deprecating if i just if dave fired me
tomorrow
there'd be like a week whatever that one
guy
and then the world would just move on to
the next like
thing that's part of the fear yes is oh
my gosh what if i'm not needed and what
if the community goes oh there's another
photographer i'll just go over there
because they still get their pictures
taken and so part of that there's a
deeper issue that you were trying to get
to which is we need to go no esther's
worth exactly what she was before she
was a photographer after and this
doesn't change anything zero things
right and one or two people are gonna
reach out five or ten or twenty people
can reach out and say hey we need to get
our photos taken where are you
oh yeah i hit pause on that i'm focusing
on my family in this season here's a
number to somebody who can call
and they'll go oh you're so good though
i know thank you so much it'll feel good
when they say that you say give
so-and-so a call he or she is great and
then you go back to being your kids
that thing your side hustle can't be
your identity because it it will come to
an end at some point or you'll find
yourself pro doing wild things taking
out crazy debt uh buying another
location to getting with partnerships
they're gonna be wild or be stupid
you're gonna find yourself doing all
these things to prop up this identity
that's not never real in the first place
yeah and then why wasn't deep enough for
me if she said hey the why is i want to
make sure that we set a financial
foundation for my family this is for a
short season that i'm doing this for to
get rid of the debt it sounds like she's
beyond that she's doing it because it's
a passion of hers and she's kind of
built up this clientele she doesn't want
to let down yeah that's a very different
reason she put the car on cruise control
now she didn't have an off ramp there
all right all right let's go to uh ryan
in greenville what's up ryan
hey uh thank you gentlemen first of all
this is very awesome to speak to you to
you all and uh i look forward to seeing
myself on youtube later so i wanted to
ask some questions i'm a newly married
man and uh
just starting off on the right foot i've
been watching y'all for a while so i'm
following the baby step baby step two
i'm almost done hopefully we can make a
trip down there and give a debt free
screen every question i'm
kind of confused with is a principal
issue and
it's this whole debt student loan
forgiveness plan
i think i shouldn't take advantage of it
even though we qualify um but when you
talk to folks even older than you they
say well you're a taxpayer you deserve
that just like anybody else you take
advantage of it you're only hurting
yourself and your family
um
i don't know i always felt like ryan
they
that's right that's right and you're
you're accountable for your own self
right you're accountable to that person
in the mirror and you're accountable to
your spouse and
uh george i love what you have to say
but thoughts here but
actually you know what ryan i've got
actually got some opinions on this yeah
let's hang on hang on to the break
because this is a can of worms that
people are asking all over the country
so i'm gonna put you on whole brother
and we're gonna go to a break and then
we'll get back we're gonna talk about
this
should i take the student loan
forgiveness when i think it's wrong am i
crazy am i setting my family up for
failure we'll answer that when we come
back
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsay to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john dalony joined here by george camel
we're talking to ryan in greenville
south carolina so ryan um just to recap
for folks who are just joining us
you qualify for the student loan
forgiveness program you and your wife
are have some student loan debt you've
got some a little kid you don't feel
like it's right you got some kids um
you've come up with with
uh your value system says i don't want
to take this money i qualify for it i
can have it i don't want it and people
are giving you advice you should do it
you're a taxpayer you deserve this all
whatever
so is that about right
that's right no kids yet though okay no
kids
no no kids so uh
why do you have this value why do you
think this why do you think that you
don't feel like you can take it
well i mean the principle on the micro
scale applied to ourselves right so
i signed something i made a commitment
to it right so i should honor my word
and keep that commitment and also i
have the sphere of influence of folks
around me that have done the same and
they made it through and they paid it
off and it was such a big boost in their
life and their marriage their strength
in their marriage their strength and
their
i guess dignity dignity and
um i feel like i want to be part of that
crowd but i'm also like am i being proud
am i being a little too proud about this
or do these older folks that say i
should take advantage of it do they have
a point is it something
it's just strange like a strange time to
live where it seems like government help
is kind of
taking precedence and i don't know like
is it sacrificing our own
accountability and
i don't know you see the consequences on
the individual scales there's got to be
global consequences no question um our
whole system is built on um that's
future us's problem
we'll let them deal with that later
right that's that's the whole system can
we punt this thing right um
george before i i'd love to get your
thoughts on we're talking about this off
here a little bit um
i find it helpful in these moments ryan
to back out of the current moment in the
politics of it all
this is this is the coven vaccine this
is um should i work at this place this
is should i take student loan
forgiveness and
these things get so hot and they get so
political and it clouds your judgment
and so i just want to back out and say
this isn't a strange time for people to
be faced with various values questions
and i'm going to answer that question
on its merits and i'm not i'm not going
to get involved in the fray and there's
something inside of you that says
i don't feel right about it george we
think i think if you're going to lose
sleep overtaking it don't do it and if
it's going to propel your financial
journey that's fine too but my issue is
kind of feeling like you're on a high
horse and you're better than folks who
took it right and you're going well i my
values say it's a bad thing i pay into
social security i don't want to do it
but am i going to take it when i retire
sure
i paid into it stimulus check we got
stimulus checks all right i'll take it
i'm not going to go like i'm going to
refund this back to the government
because i don't believe in stimulus
checks so i just don't think it's a i
disagree with the entire premise of it
but i also don't have a strong enough
moral compass to go
absolutely not
and you bring up something important
ryan
let me tell you how i personally deal
with these things right so i take the
politics out of it and then i make my
decision
and then i tell no one
because if i feel like i have to
announce my values my personal values
and my personal choices to the world
then it's i'm i'm virtue signaling i'm
not sticking by a principle i'm doing
something so that i can make an
announcement about it instead of this is
a personal value like when people uh
take social media fast and they have a
big post about why they're taking it
fast because they're better than all of
us for getting off social media like
that john
like that so ryan
if if man if your value say don't take
it don't take it and don't lose a second
of sleep over it and here's the thing
you don't have to you don't have to
you're going to ask 40 different people
you're going to get 40 different answers
right right so
sit with your wife and you'll make this
decision on your own that one that you
can sleep with and then let that be your
decision and let this be practice for
future
values based decisions you're going
gonna have to make in the future
and let them be yours and yours alone i
think one of the challenges we've run
into is we have to make hard decisions
in our lives and then now we have a
platform to tell everybody about them
and it quickly divides up the world and
people stop being neighbors and they
stop being
parents on this on a softball league or
parents sit on the sidelines of a kid's
dance recital and it becomes
you versus me and man stick by your
values love them be good about it and
then go on with your day does that sound
fair
that sounds fair cool man well
congratulations for even having even
thinking about it right well another
piece of this he mentioned is you know
the character
uh that you develop by sacrificing and
paying off debt i think he's already
experienced that i don't think he's
gonna miss out on it by getting 10k
forgiven right and so for that piece i
say yes it absolutely changes your
character and how you look at money when
you had to pay it off and i'm happy for
those people there's amazing personal
growth there he's already experienced
that i don't think he's going to revert
back to i'm just going to wait on
everyone to fix my life ryan he's
already done this stuff right i think
the key is whether you take care of
whether you don't
don't wear it as a badge of this just
elevated me above you exactly personal
choice you made cool let's move on with
their day right i love that thanks for
the call um ryan that's that's helpful
for folks all right let's go to hunter
in little rock arkansas what's up hunter
hey guys thanks for the time today of
course man the question is directed to
george and him and i have actually been
talking a little bit on direct message
and
the basics is i'm six thousand dollars
in debt and i'm 18 years old i make
shy of 15 an hour and i work overnight
and i'm just struggling with getting the
baby steps going figuring out how it all
works
my debt consists of about 2 000 towards
my parents for my vehicle
a few other small little
debts to my mom in general and then i
actually financed a bunch of um
iphone ipad stuff through my service
provider and unfortunately i've missed
the time to
return all that stuff and i don't really
want to sell it and take a hit so i
guess i'm just trying to figure out how
to get the baby steps going and how to
make that thousand dollar emergency fund
as a starter whenever that seems like a
good amount of money i could do to put
towards that debt um
it's a great question and you know at 18
i remember being that age and i was also
buying every apple product out there and
this starts the baby steps don't work
unless you decide to take debt off the
table so we've got to stop financing got
to stop going to family for loans which
is just going to destroy relationships
in the end uh so number one i would look
at trying to get your income up i know
you're already crushing it you're
working overnights you're doing
everything you can i would see in your
area if there's anything else that can
pay more in this job market right now
that will help increase that shovel
because six thousand dollars is not a
large amount of debt you know in the
grand scheme of things but to you it
looks like a mountain doesn't it
yes a lot and you're like sisyphus
pushing up the rock every day watching
it come back down going how do i climb
out of this hole so number one we gotta
get on a written plan every one of those
fifteen dollars an hour coming in
they're going to have a job and the job
is not going to be finance stuff and go
into more debt it's going to be paying
off this debt so your a1 is getting a
thousand dollars and if that means
selling a few of these pieces these
apple products whatever you got laying
around i'm good with that
even if you take us a slight hit because
right now it's not about what makes
sense uh math-wise it's about behavior
change and i want you to feel a little
bit of pain going oh gosh i paid a
thousand i just sold it for 600. that
hurt that makes sense
can you do it harder another part are
you willing to do it sorry what are you
willing to do
i'm willing to do it i'm like i said i'm
a little scared to take the hit but i'm
willing to do what it takes
i guess my follow-up question with that
though is we talked about financial
peace i thought about doing it and i'm
kind of wondering if that is a
good idea
for being a hundred dollars whenever
that just seems like more that could go
into my emergency fund
um well you know as my gift to you since
we've been dming on instagram i'll gift
it to you today uh as our our gift to
you to get on this stuff but you gotta
promise me you're actually gonna watch
every single video get on a plan start
every dollar as soon as you get off this
call and go no more
today is where hunter's life begins to
change we gotta look in the mirror and
stop making these decisions
we're gonna start making adult decisions
if we want to see some adult progress
so hang online austin will pick up we're
going to gift you financial peace
university and the premium version of
every dollar call us back man when
you're debt-free i'd love to hear about
it
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
we are back on the ramsey show and on
the debt free stage
right down the street from us we've got
jb
nashville tennessee and i'm assuming
you've paid off everything yes sir how
much we paid off brother 108 000. 108
000 how long did it take you uh 30
months 30 months what was your income uh
ranged from 80 000 to 125
to 125. what do you do for a living
i've been in supply chain for my whole
career but recently pivoted into uh
solutions consulting for a large tech
company wow
you guys really got off the rails for
the last few years oh yeah it was a good
time to get out of supply chain right
now from this point forward anytime
there's a supply i'm just like
just blame me
get it together dude what kind of debt
was it 108
loans student loans i had i had less
than a thousand in uh consumer debt
credit cards and an iphone but yeah all
students what was the degree
supply chain and business analytics um
but you know i lived off my loans i did
an extra year i wasn't ready to graduate
so i did the victory lap
got another major studied abroad i did
all the things in college but i was
hanging on for dear life yeah i was
living for the moment and i wasn't
thinking anything about my future that's
a problem for future jb yeah that's
right later you kick the cam down the
road that's right yeah so uh what
happened 30 months ago you're like dude
i'm done i'm done with all this yeah so
uh coming out of just some backstory
coming out of college having over 120
right when i graduated
i at least 30 of my paycheck was going
towards minimum payments for those loans
so i was really living paycheck to
paycheck and using my credit cards to to
live um
but fast forward to the beginning of
2020 in february my brother-in-law he
knew my situation but him and my sister
also had
some of their own loans to clean up so
they started their journey they read the
total money makeover and he gifted that
book to me and i think it was the
quickest book i ever read and i remember
distinctly like getting so pumped up i
was reading the book before bed one
night i cut up all my credit cards
immediately got the envelopes out
started writing you know what allocation
they went to but
yeah i just started to
to commit to a life change so what
caused that level of visceral reaction
where you just went all right tonight
i'm done exhaustion like i
like i said living paycheck to paycheck
and and having this huge burden i was
thinking about my future too like i i
always wanted to buy a house you know
have a family someday start that whole
thing but that was not going to be a
possibility with that huge cloud hanging
over my head
uh how old are you man i'm 30 30 30 in
april just turned 30.
was it like
uh
being here in nashville the last couple
of years you make good money
and deciding intentionally to not go out
to not go to these shows there's a show
every weekend right um then i'll go to
the shows and not go out to eat at these
fabulous restaurants that cost
part of your soul right they're
expensive how'd you do that man that's
hard because there's a lot of dudes
you're a good-looking guy you're you're
just turned 30 you're just officially
old now but like for both you're in your
20s i mean that's the
that's like the yolo season right and
you chose to
plant seeds for fruit you're going to
eat 15 20 30 years down the road
man
yeah how'd you do that yeah i suffered
terminally from fomo it's it's it is
it's brutal i want to i want to do
everything i'm a really social person
and saying no to eating out you know
going to those concerts and
vacations that i haven't seen the beach
in three years and you know
saying no to all that was so so hard but
i knew you know
two and a half years in the grand scheme
of my life as a drop in the bucket and
okay but that's the level of wisdom that
most
65 year olds don't have right
a where does that come from and b like i
want to get tactical mechanistically
yeah somebody calls and says hey i got
front row seats to whatever or hey
so-and-so is coming to town let's go
watch that show or
um somebody that you've really had your
eye on they're like let's go to dinner
yeah and
walk us through what do you what do you
what did you do to stop yourself or to
be able to be at peace or to make
decisions otherwise because there's a
bunch of people say i can't do that
right i just can't do that and i always
say yes you can like oh no i can't yeah
how did you do it truthfully i couldn't
have done it on my own okay like i i
rely on my faith in the holy spirit to
get me through that and be my
steadfastness and endurance throughout
that whole process but also being
overly transparent with my close friends
and family and you know you'd think
they'd think i'm crazy for saying no to
everything and i took on four you know
three extra jobs four extra jobs at us
you know certain times um i had no time
for anything but just
inviting them into the struggle a little
bit and being like hey i love you guys i
want to spend time with you you know i
want to be at this concert but i want to
get out of debt more
and they were they were so bought in too
and they were so loving and supportive
and they would find time to like take me
out for meals or you know just spend
quality time with me and that was some
really you know special times i'll
remember george i've heard it's a great
pick-up line to meet somebody and say hi
my name is jb
i would like to be your boyfriend we are
going to have to go on walks for the
next 24 months
because i'm not buying you anything a
lot of uh uh dog park dates and you know
yeah he doesn't even have a coffee date
that's so cool that you have great
friends that respected those boundaries
and cheered you on this journey that's
huge
um i also got to know what are these
four jobs you had because people are
always going what's a good side hustle
and you did this stuff yeah
so i had my main full-time gig um
and i also i did postmates and instacart
on the side for a time
i worked at a i was a janitor at my
church i worked at a vineyard here in
town um and the most fun and creative
way i uh self-published some children's
books on the side wow so that was kind
of a fun way to being in supply chain
it's a pretty dry subject and so that
was a nice way to stay creative and use
the other side of my brain you've heard
the kids book on the supply chain
very educational
that's right it's just a uh it's just
like a snow globe that everybody's just
shake it up what was the most lucrative
of the side gigs um
honestly most probably the vineyard uh
the vineyard was a but it was also a
great experience to just work outside
use my hands get to work with a bunch of
great people and
um pretend you're in the south of france
people tip great when they drink a lot
of wine that helped that helped too wow
so who's your biggest cheerleader
brother oh i had so many um
my mom she's here with me she was
definitely rooting me on from the side
of my whole family my brother-in-law
earl who gifted me that total money
maker we were we overlapped in our
debt-free journey so he was kind of
accountability partner for me and really
kept me going you know praying for each
other having check-in you know phone
calls but um man my my friends here in
town were with me
through every single day and you know
regular life and they were just rooting
me on the whole way
what what if somebody said one of your
buddies pulled you aside and said hey
what's the one thing i got to do what
would it be to get out of debt
um
getting on a budget and actually
sticking to it all
from once when i graduated i had an
excel budget but it was just an excel
document that i had never opened
it was it was never used
i rarely open excel files as well so
no shame it's like george used to date
he's like i'm dating somebody we never
talk we don't talk they don't call me
yeah we've never spoken
but yeah it was really pretty and
colorful but i've never used it but
actually building that discipline and
saying no
to things and actually sticking to the
the plan that i have for myself was
absolutely vital how does it feel man
it's wild it i think it's going to sink
in more and more as i can enjoy i just
paid off my own in august so i'm really
just like that's trash you've got that
have you gotten that one paycheck yeah
it's all yours
yeah but then i had some car issues some
merchants
yeah yeah but so that's what i'm saying
like as as time goes on and i'll be able
to enjoy my income more and more it'll
sink in was it cool though when the car
thing happened it was annoying it was an
inconvenience it was annoying yeah it
was like you know darn yeah
we're so proud of you man we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story as
you build wealth and be incredibly
generous and we also have a copy of the
total money makeover pass it on to one
of your friends who didn't fully
understand what was going on why jb went
crazy all of a sudden and one year of
financial peace university that you can
go through with all the new lessons with
me and john that's really the selling
point yes congratulations that's what
you get
you get out of debt you got to watch the
videos all right so we got jb from
nashville tennessee paid off a hundred
and eight thousand dollars in 30 months
making 80 to 125 000
sometimes working up to four jobs to get
this
done brother congratulations thank you
count them down
three two one
i'm dead free
[Applause]
[Music]
and a yihaw to that john it's a very
nashville yeehaw to that very natural
what a stud
that guy's incredible you just gotta
make the choice
i'm gonna do this no matter what it
takes
ta-da it happens
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john deloney joined here by george
campbell and george you have really
screwed up i did nothing john i'm gonna
agree to disagree with you and so would
all of the internet there's been some
news um
people are mourning all over the world
of course for the queen yes
huge news very sad
but also in much less important
frivolous news infinitely less important
chipotle employees say they're thrilled
the changes crack down on the three
dollar burrito ordering hack that was
making their lives miserable so i want
to see i want to plot this out on how it
works
you go on the internets and tell
everybody hey you're overpaying here's
how to beat the system and the system
rises up against the people
courtesy of george
i had very little to do with this
i never encourage the three dollar
burrito because i'm gluten free i can't
literally call yourself an influencer
and you've influenced the man okay
here's the hack i did share with america
many times over the last few years
is loading up with all the extra
toppings so chipotle lets you add you
can add extra rice extra fajita veggies
extra except guac that one's extra you
got to pay for that and so here's what
here's what people went wrong
they started ordering a single taco
which i encourage and get all the
toppings on it
but where people went wrong they started
asking for all of those toppings
inside cups
as in 14 side cups with your single taco
and a tortilla on the side which is an
extra 40 cents so it came out to about a
three dollar burrito instead of you know
the nine or ten dollar burrito great
hack right except for
chipotle employees uh saying that the
orders were beyond annoying and
disruptive and saying it was a disaster
behind the scenes five chipotle workers
in five states who asked to remain
anonymous as they were not authorized to
speak to the press whose identities are
known to insider explain why they hated
making these viral orders
i just picture them like with the black
shadow like silhouette
in like a voice changer on
like it was annoying
but i get it if you've ever worked in an
environment in the fast casual world in
hospitality it's tough it is very very
stressful so when you have a line of 84
people and then everyone's like can i
have every single side in a little tiny
side cup and it takes you 17 minutes for
that one person's order all so they can
save a few bucks understandably
frustrating and so chipotle put a stop
to the hack on wednesday they said it
was a huge waste of single-use plastic
there you go they used the green card
right there boom different different
different green cards that's right and
they said it was horribly obvious what
customers using the hack were trying to
do and it was annoying for everyone
trying to just do their jobs it was a
poor experience for the our food the
employees and our customers waiting on
orders
it would have been cool if they just
said hey we're gonna make all of our
burritos three dollars
that would be nice well here's what they
went wrong with inflation they jacked up
the price of all of their food to like
ten dollars just for starters now yeah
so uh people are starting to revolt john
they're looking for the hacks well
thanks to you george
you can blame me if you want oppressors
are closing the loopholes man if i have
that much influence in the fast casual
world i'm doing something right
so you should probably never say casual
again all right blinds.com is 100
satisfaction guaranteed means even if
you mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal today's question comes
from rachel in idaho i listen to your
show a lot and often hear you in the
team talk about contentment which is
very important currently my husband and
i are in baby steps four five and six
and happy with our lives and house
however our dream is to have a house
with some acreage for a small farm we're
29 and 37 how can we mentally balance
contentment versus our future goals hmm
what do you think man well i know john
you're you're a big fan of uh you know
living off the fat of the land and all
that you live in the middle of nowhere
with no cell service so this is more you
guys align with this dream right and
you've always wanted to have a big plot
of land and i love that we've got a
place where you can plug in your tesla
there we go thank you john but she's
asking how do we balance contentment we
want this land we're happy with where we
live here's our future goal we're trying
to invest save for the kids college we
want to pay the house off but we also
want this next thing yeah and so
balancing that they're asking mentally
balancing it financially it's pretty
simple you get these plates spinning get
investing put a little away for college
let's pay off the house and then get
investing put a little away for college
let's pay off the house and as you build
that equity you'll be able to roll that
over as you start to look for this new
piece of land in the future
and that takes some patience when it
comes to
i guess mentally i don't know if i'd say
it like that but when it comes to just
being present where you are and having
big dreams
uh one of the criticisms i get when i'm
meeting with people behind closed doors
i'll travel across the country meet with
leaders and business owners and we'll
sit down and we'll talk through being
well what that looks like and how to
create wellness in your home and how do
executives stay well and the pushback
generally comes from what am i supposed
to do then if all these things i'm doing
in my life are killing me am i supposed
to just not run a business anymore am i
supposed to not be ambitious anymore
and i always tell them no absolutely not
in fact the opposite
my two little kids are growing up in the
systems that these guys are building
these men and women are creating and
running right now right i need them to
be ambitious we got big problems we got
to solve
i also need them to know
that that extra zero that they earn
will not
make up for the fact that their dad left
right the the
getting this new piece of acreage isn't
gonna suddenly be the place where your
marriage materializes into peaceful
enjoy and hope and all this great stuff
you're still going to have fights when
you live on this big property your
marriage is still going to be hard and
so
dream big and
take concrete steps like you're talking
about to see those dreams through and
know full well those dreams won't fix me
it won't solve my marriage won't make my
kids suddenly fill in the plank right
unless you are in
um you are in situations where people
are absolutely not safe right then
getting them out of safety definitely
helps everything right so it's being
able to balance let's do the small
things to make sure our marriage is
whole to make sure we're great parents
we're plugged in and we're connected we
love our small community and we're doing
this thing because we want we want this
life not because this life is going to
do something for us right and we tend to
cash in our present day joy for this
this
mystical joy that's going to come down
the road and doesn't work like that
right well you heard the old saying like
wherever you show up you're going to go
too right you go with you
and part of this is we just live in this
microwave culture where it's like i want
it now two hour delivery now i can't
wait two days and so part of that bleeds
into our life goals and we're looking
for shortcuts now we go well we could
just take on the bigger mortgage we
could do the heloc we can borrow from
our 401k and you're looking for all
these terrible shortcuts to get you to
where you want to go
but if you just sit down on paper and go
all right that new property is going to
cost 500 000
our home is worth 300. what if we get
that paid off in the next three years
then we start saving up we have an extra
2000 we could buy this thing with cash
six years from now right and you start
to put that on paper and instead of
letting it deflate you you let it fuel
you and go all right this is what we're
gonna be about and it's gonna take six
years but guess what you're 29 and 37.
people think it's too late at that like
well i should have had it at 25 right
right
and you look up and you go dude you're
gonna live to be like a thousand with
technology and healthcare these days you
got plenty of time
slow down enjoy the ride smell the roses
and be proud of yourselves where you're
at out of debt completely investing for
the future with financial peace
george when you look down the road for
you what are some things you're excited
about
well as you know john we're ambitious
people my wife works here at ramsey and
so i found that contentment ambition uh
their their next door neighbors and they
can get along peacefully yeah when we
aren't always going what's the next
thing what's the next thing and we have
a tendency to do that
i'm very guilty of this and ramsay's
just a very driven place we're very
competitive we're always focused on
goals so what has helped us is just to
sit in silence and look around and go
this is the house we dreamed about right
five years ago yep and this is the life
we would have dreamt about when we were
broken and dead it's very rare that
people recognize they're standing in the
middle of a blessing yes because you
look at your neighbor and like oh man
his grass is a lot greener you go to his
yard and you're like oh his yard
actually sucks it just looks different
from the angle i have this home that you
all are living in is the answer to one
of your grandparents prayers for y'all
yes right this home you are living in is
the culmination of a bunch of people
making hard choices throughout the years
to move their families across oceans and
across cultures and
for this moment right and there's
something about sitting in that and
saying
huh
all right when you do it without
shortcuts it changes the way you view it
that's right because it's a blessing and
not a curse and we sleep well at night
knowing that we're not over here sitting
with piles of debt trying to live this
facade of a life to impress anyone
that's right every decision i make is
just going i think this is going to
benefit me and my family and we've
earned it and i would recommend anybody
who says hey we want to get a bunch of
land we want to do a tiny house thing we
want to live an event
take a week of your vacation this
upcoming year and go to a dude ranch and
work it right get a van go go try out
this life before you let it be go milk
some cows there you go before you think
it's going to solve everything hey
that's an hour in the books here at the
ramsey show we'll be right back stay
with us
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio this is the
ramsay show where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life your
marriage and your relationships and your
money i'm john deloney joined here by
george campbell and we are taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to pete in
dayton ohio what's up pete
hey guys thanks for taking my call happy
friday you got it yeah man what's up
hey uh so my question is should i
contribute more towards the home
mortgage or should i max out my roth ira
looking at the rest of the year
well i don't see it as in either or if
you're following the baby steps you'd be
investing 15
in baby step four are you currently
investing 15 percent
yeah and so this year i switched jobs
and i recently got married uh three
weeks ago so congrats
thank you thank you yeah so i just moved
in with uh with my wife and so i i just
started making payments on the home and
i've been investing 10 percent all year
just because of the employer match
but now and i usually do the roth ira
the full 6000 as well
and so now is that time that i'm
thinking about doing it but i didn't
know if it would be
if the interest saved on the home that i
would use that money uh if if that
outweighs the gains in the long term if
that makes sense
i would be investing 15 regardless and
then any money beyond that we can throw
at the house so if you're sitting there
at 10 and trying to throw money at the
mortgage because of interest it's a bad
plan
okay
so you're investing 10 percent now so
we're going to ramp that up to 15 and we
say match beats roth me means beats
traditional so do you have a match
through your employer you said how much
is that
i do it's it's uh they match 2.5
okay so regardless of the match we're
still investing 15 percent of our income
okay so don't bring that down because of
the match and beyond the match you can
then fully fund the roth ira is it a
roth 401k or traditional
it's a roth 401k okay
i personally just do all 15 of my roth
401k and you can do the same just keep
it simple you don't need to max out the
roth until you know you hit your 401k
limit and then you can look at that
maybe a backdoor roth if your income is
too high at that point so you can look
into those options but no we do these
steps uh in sequential order for a
reason and we want you to retire with
dignity build wealth and as part of that
plan the house will get paid off uh
shortly
all right let's go to stephanie in
chinatown chicago what is up stephanie
hi thank you for taking my call um so my
husband and i are kind of in a
predicament with the housing market
um we've been in our house for 10 years
recently refinanced to 15 that now down
to 14 at 2.6 percent
uh we owe about a hundred and five
thousand
but
it's a seller's market so
we're wondering should we sell
and
save the equity uh which would probably
be about 165
move in with my mom for a year or two
or should we maybe dump a little money
in the house and just wait it out and
maybe sell in three to five years
why do you want to sell
why do you feel this urge to sell
so the cons are the public schools in
the area um so if we decide to stay in
the area our son would have to go to
private school so
tuition is about 4 000 a year we're
still about two years out from that
um the other con is we live in a duplex
and
now that we've been there for 10 years
we've had two neighbors and we're
experiencing issues with
trying to get the roof repaired um
trying to have them be on the same page
as us also privacy issues
so those are really two of the biggest
comms um
obviously we're happy with the rate and
what we owe on the mortgage so right now
we're just focused on paying that down
and saving for retirement
well are you stuck in the area you're in
can you move further away
and buy something else
we could we could move further out but
family wise we want to stay somewhat
local just to be close to both my mom
and my sister and nephew and we also
want the good schools
we want a better school absolutely we've
already decided if we stay in the area
he has to go to the private school and
we move into a better area i want a
million dollars
and a pony that can fly right you see
i'm saying like at some point
i know so at some point you got to deal
with reality right you know like you
know that show um the house hunters when
they're like okay our budget is a 65 000
and we want
three ocean views and it's like and the
realtor is like all right so at some
point i'll be honest with you okay we're
very focused on saving for retirement we
do feel like we're in a great spot
financially for our age but i'm very
focused on us being comfortable in
retirement so what are you making out
here we don't want
so comfortably both of us together we're
at 155 combined income and no debt with
a fully funded emergency fund and
investing 15 percent
we have absolutely zero debt aside from
monthly day care which is
1170. we have about
240 000
in retirement assets
55 000 in liquid assets savings and eye
bonds and 40 000 in a joint investment
account
and that's just a taxable brokerage
account outside of retirement correct so
why don't you sell the house and not
live with mom and just go get a new
place that's reasonable
we can't seem to find what we need right
now inventory feels pretty low in all of
the surrounding areas
what's going to happen is you're going
to move in with your parents waiting for
a unicorn to show up are you moving with
your mom waiting for unicorn to show up
and it's going to end up burning your
marriage relationship it's going to end
up burning your relationship between
your mom and your husband it's just
gonna get to be a mess
i i'm okay people moving into their
parents but it's gotta be everybody sits
at a table and has a very
clear
timeline if it means waiting on the
market that's a bad thing right here
we're gonna do it for six months we're
gonna save up fourteen thousand dollars
and we're going to move out that
this deck we're just going to want to
sell and then we're just going to kind
of float around is a recipe for
resentment and disaster but i would not
hang on to this this mortgage because
it's a low interest rate that's a
terrible reason to be miserable right
okay so you recommend that we sell take
the equity in and find another home cash
out everything that is not your
emergency fund and everything that's
non-retirement and use that with the
equity to step into a house and if you
do with our parameters 15-year fixed
rate no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay you're going to have a
great down payment then you will have
some financial peace in that decision
and you're going to have to cash out the
i'm sorry you're saying cash out the
joint investment brokerage
okay and use that towards it as well
because our next goal like you mentioned
let's pay off the house and let's build
wealth and so part of that we need to be
thrown at the house right now once we
have that paid off then we can have some
fun and build even more wealth beyond
that 15
and while i've got you stephanie can i
press on you for one minute
yes
i want you to make the emotional
psychological and spiritual exercise of
the next 12 months of your life
learning to
and
practicing living where you are
you are somebody that is living two
years ahead five years ahead 15 years
ahead 20 years ahead
and you're gonna get there and you're
gonna realize you didn't live
you're gonna realize you spent all those
years planning for things so make sure
you are living in the present right now
where you are not just always planning
and looking and looking down and then
when you get here and then we get here
make sure you have some good times that
little boy make sure you and your
husband are having some laughs and some
fun live your life we'll be right back
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
hey we know a lot of you are scared
right now between inflation and debt
payments you feel like you're drowning
and you're terrified you won't have
enough to take care of your family
you shouldn't have to live in fear
but you do have to get to a point where
you said i've had it and then decide
you're ready to make a change
because you can't keep doing the same
things with money and expect different
results and that means it's time to try
financial peace university this course
will teach you our step-by-step plan to
beat debt save for emergencies and build
wealth that's worked for millions you've
rolled your eyes you've got tmmo total
money makeover on a shelf that some
grandmother gave you is time
and right now we're offering an edit
we're offering it at the lowest price
we've ever offered it
we know what's going on in the hearts
and minds of people when it comes to
finances because we take your calls
every day we know we know and so instead
of doing what everyone else is doing
with inflation making things more
expensive
we're here to help people man we like to
we got to pay our rent and all that but
we like to help people so we are
offering it the lowest price we've ever
lowered it i offered it because you all
need it so stop living in fear you can
take control of your money with
financial peace university get started
right now at ramseysolutions.com
fpu it's ramseysolutions.comfpu
all right let's go to chris in fargo
what's up brother chris
hi guys thanks for taking my call you
got it man what's up
um
i talked to you a couple weeks ago dr
john um
my son passed away
now i'm dealing with the logistics of
everything yeah
walk walk the listeners here you called
on my show um a couple weeks ago
uh
walk us through what's going on what
happened
um he was killed by a drunk driver
um
on a side-by-side atv
and
i responded to the call as a firefighter
yeah so
yeah it's rare that a show stays with me
and my time with you stayed with me man
and um
just dad to dad um once you know i'm
still thinking about you and i'm
grateful for your honesty and for
um
how are you before we get to the the
nuts and bolts here how are you
i'm good surviving yeah getting help
yeah therapy um
friends good it's a little much at times
but i'm doing good yeah a few weeks
after your son passed away survival
makes sense right survival's where you
need to be right now and good for you
for reaching out to other folks
um this is your first responder you know
this better than most
george this is the other side of
somebody we love passing away we often i
i often sit with folks overwhelmed by
the mechanics the nuts and bolts right
um everything from what about the car
what about i mean just stuff right what
do we do and so um i appreciate you
reaching out with a mechanics question
so how can we help
um so
we had two 529s
and
i instant run out instantly but i rolled
my son's into my other son's 529 so
there's about 58 000
in his 529 and he's 15 years old
and there's a debate between my wife and
i do we keep investing in 529 or to set
money aside
so we have access to it if he doesn't
use it
that makes sense yeah
do you know have you talked to your son
about this i mean obviously he's 15 we
don't know what the future looks like
and where he's gonna go to college but
uh do you think he'll plan on going to
college
he's definitely college bound okay um
we'll have to set the parameters for him
you're not going to ivy league and never
had the illusion that i was going to pay
for it all
that money there was to help both of
them
well i don't even know how much college
cost i would a billion dollars i would
continue contributing i'd rather have
too much for college than not enough and
have to be rushing to fill in the gap as
he's heading off to college and he's
gone you know i want him to have some
skin in the game too here and going all
right i'm gonna apply for as many
scholarships and grants as i can i'm
gonna work part-time while in college
i'm going to work from now until i go to
college to have that income and if he
doesn't need it and your 529 plan funds
cover it that's great that's going to be
an amazing kickstarter to his future and
allow him to to live and graduate with
some plans but i would continue
contributing to it because that money
will grow and even over three years if
you can get you know eight nine ten
eleven percent growth in that account on
that money you're putting in i'm going
to take that
chris can i
give you a different piece of wisdom
sure
i would recommend
not a different piece of wisdom what
georgia said is is totally accurate
right
okay i want you to take a break for a
minute though
here's why
from
making as few long-term decisions as
possible
here's why like so i just had dinner
with him last night his name's dr andy
young he's here in town nashville doing
a training for first responders he's the
guy that trained me on crisis response
and also he sat with me during a couple
of personal issues that i went through
personal crisis stuff
and one of his rules of thumb is six
months to a year after something
significant don't make don't quit your
job don't move houses don't sell cars
stay as stable as you can
and my guess is right now part of the
conversation you and your wife are
having is based in a in a nihilistic
world view
why are we even putting money in this
thing who the crap knows what's gonna
happen in three years you see what i'm
saying y'all are still in the grieving
process and trying to make rational
long-term money decisions on the back
end of this thing it's just not the time
to do it that's not the season to do it
especially if you don't have to
and so i love george's idea let's just
keep contributing like we were and if
you look up in a year and you've got a
little bit too much money in there you
can tell your kid well hey we've got
more in there for you right um if you
end up not with enough y'all can have a
hard conversation in the next 18 months
and say hey you've got 18 months until
you go to college and it's what that's
going to look like but
the fewer
we got to solve this and got to solve
this and i get the energy as a dad you
want to do something feel like you got
to be doing something
um
do as few big things as possible okay
just park for a minute yeah y'all are
still healing right and you and your
wife are going to get into disagreements
that y'all don't there's no reason to
get into them you'll have enough going
on between the two of you trying to
both grieve this thing
then to throw like we should do this we
shouldn't do this it could happen in
five years man that's just not the time
for those conversations is that fair
that's fair cool
um well we're still thinking about you
and your family man um i don't think
that um chris thanks for calling that
george i don't think that episode's
aired yet but it was uh
one of the hardest calls i've ever taken
ever on the john delaney shows it was
tough stuff tough it's a great great man
and a great family and a great community
that's rallying up around him but i
think i think
globally speaking
um when we experience hard things
whether it's we lose a child whether
it's we have a car wreck whether it's we
get fire
our impulse is just to run right that's
the fight or flight we're just in it
we're going to do stuff we got to be
busy go action
and sometimes the wisest thing we can do
is exhale and back up a little bit right
and just slow down and you've talked
about when you're grieving your brain is
not firing on all cylinders no
absolutely not you're just in a fault
it's in survival that's right great
decisions aren't going to happen in
those moments right
yeah you usually default to training or
that's why you have friends
right we say that you know your
community is your emergency fund for
life because life will happen to you and
when i'm not in a place to make great
choices to great make great decisions
well i'm just gonna sell the house in i
got divorced i'm just gonna sell my
house i'm gonna move across don't do
anything chill chill chill chill that's
what your friends are for right they
come in and they show up with tacos they
show up with casserole they lift your
arms up in the desert when you're just
exhausted and they show up and help mow
the yard when you aren't even thinking
about it they say hey
let's don't cash out your retirement
let's just sit let's just wait for a
couple of months and see if the fall
clears right maybe making a list of
here's what has to happen here's the
financial things we have to deal with
because a divorce happened a job loss
we're grieving the loss of a loved one
and here's everything that we need to
deal with but it's not that important or
urgent right now that's brilliant it's
on i've sat with people in the middle of
the night who have to go to work it's on
a friday they got to work on monday
because there's no money and dad just
died her husband just died her wife just
passed away like there's a reality an
urgency
i've also sat with folks who
because they had a will because things
were taken care of they've got some
space just to grieve and that's a
totally different place to be so i love
that idea of saying okay what what is on
fire right now and what are some things
we're gonna have to deal with the
insurance we're gonna have to deal with
the with the
you know the fill in the car dealership
we're gonna have to deal with whatever
let's deal with that later let's just
spend some time grieving let's spend
some time learning how to breathe again
it's tough tough season i thought it was
in there chris we're praying for you my
brother we're with you we'll be right
back on the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you that's why you need to get in touch
with churchill mortgage to make sure you
do this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
dolone joined with me by george campbell
let's go to tina in los angeles what's
up tina
hey
how are you good how are you
oh doing well good good what's up
so i was wondering
should i keep using my credit cards and
building up my credit score i pay them
off right away um so i just should i
keep using those and then also um i've
been contributing to my 401k for almost
10 years now since i started working at
my at my current job and should i keep
contributing that or
contributing to that or should i stop
how much debt are you in tina
um well
along with my car i'm about 30 000 in
debt okay what other debt do you have
other than the car
just the car and like a couple credit
cards okay but the credit cards are very
small yeah okay so to answer your first
question no you should not continue to
use the credit card to build your score
let me ask you why you want to build the
score
um it's just
financial advice from my parents it was
like you know yeah cash is have good to
have but also a good credit score is
also really really good to have been
there been there that is how i grew up
learning about the credit score at 18
you got to get a credit card to build
the scores you can go into debt so you
can get more debt so you can get a good
score do you see the vicious cycle this
has created
yeah and so when it comes to the credit
score i uh you know i've lived with that
one for many many years obviously when i
got a mortgage you get a score again um
but as far as keeping the score and
keeping using the credit cards for that
you don't need it because we're not
going to go into car debt again
because debt is not your friend and it's
stealing from your paycheck every month
and as far as everything else goes you
can rent hotels you can rent cars you
can do all kinds of things with a debit
card do you have one of those
yeah okay
so tonight what if we had an exercise
where we cut up the cards and tried to
live on our debit card and paid off
these credit cards and never looked back
okay does that sound fun to you
oh my gosh wow
is this excitement are you like that
sounds crazy i was like yeah that's a
little bit crazy but i mean
we're crazy around that level
do you know why is it crazy about credit
cards for about five years i just barely
got them again because i think it's
crazy to be like in the matrix and
playing this game of what does fico
think about me am i credit worthy
i mean does that not sound a little
crazy here's the truth tina if we wrote
you a check for a million dollars
and you didn't use your credit card for
a month you just put that million
dollars in the bank in your bank your
credit score would go down
because credit score has nothing to do
with your financial position it has to
do with your love affair with debt
so let me walk you through what's going
to happen you are going to pay off all
of your debt and never look back
including the car loan what's your
income
i make 75 a year awesome okay what's the
car worth
um well when i got it it was
26.
okay so that's a reasonable car for your
income we say that we don't want more
than 50 percent of your income tied up
in with things and motors in them
because they go down in value which your
card is doing as we speak
so if you're following our plan which i
assume you're you're newer to this this
craziness
i just started listening to this show
about like a week and a half why did you
come to us tina what's happening in your
life
well um
i was i was in a very bad financial
place a few years ago and i just had two
babies
um so my credit went down and it took a
while until i got like some promotions
at work and that it started coming back
up but then i kind of noticed once my
income started going up
um the lifestyle i guess started going
up too and now i'm just like i'm not
just like uh you know i'm
i need to stop like i need to get get it
together and um i was just looking for
like some financial um
how do i say this advice like and i went
on
the podcast app on apple and i found you
guys
that is awesome very cool we're so glad
you're here that's a huge step just to
hate the situation you're in most people
are comfortable sitting in their own
poop and i'm glad you've decided to take
a step in that direction so when it
comes to our plan we have a proven plan
called the baby steps 10 million people
have done this including myself
including john and it works
so a1 is getting a thousand dollars
saved for a starter emergency fund do
you have a thousand dollars in the bank
um
not yet
okay that's going to be our a1 if that
means selling stuff side hustles working
extra i don't care we're going to do
this in less than 30 days can you do
that
um yeah i can sell that i'm on salary so
i'm like on a fixed income you know
great that means you got to fix your
your unfixed expenses
true that means we're getting on a
budget cutting back a whole lot like no
going out to eat no more eating out none
none
none what's your favorite place to go
out to eat tina what what is your like
guilty plea like i'm going if i'm
getting take out tonight on a friday
here's where i'm going
oh my gosh sushi okay bye felicia you're
not gonna have sushi for a long time new
restaurant town is called sucasa you're
gonna eat at your house tina
best restaurant in town it's a whole
experience you get to make your own food
you're gonna love it
so you're gonna get on a budget we're
gonna help with that because you're a
new listener i'm super excited on the
plan we're going to gift you one year
financial peace university as well as
every dollar our budgeting app so that
you can make a plan for every single one
of these 75 000 coming in and it is
going to be so freeing i know you hear
the word budget like gross no i'm
telling you this is permission to spend
and you're gonna feel so confident about
the next steps
so on top of the thousand dollar starter
then we're gonna move to getting rid of
all this debt using the debt snowball so
list out your debts smallest to largest
ignoring the interest rate does that
sound crazy too
a little bit good
because culture is normal so we got to
be a little weird don't we
right all right so we're going to list
them out smallest to largest make
minimum payments and all the debts and
attack that little one with a vengeance
probably those little credit cards right
mm-hmm yeah and then we're going to cut
them up when they're paid off and say no
more
tina is the bank now tina's her own
lender
and once we do that we're going to beef
up that emergency fund to three to six
months
then we invest do you know what that
means tina
it means we're not going to invest until
then it means we're going to stop the
401k contributions also sounds crazy
right
a little bit yeah because i've been
building it up for almost 10 years i
know this is a crazy train it'll still
grow you'll you'll still get compound
growth what you put in there but right
now we need to make progress and we need
to change our behavior and you're doing
14 things at once which is what got you
here right
right so let's try to do one thing at a
time with focused intensity
and if you hate it hey in six months
from now if you're not in a better
financial situation you can go back to
tina's plan eating sushi putting money
in the 401k putting everything on credit
cards and hoping for the best buying
visa bigger buildings for themselves
with at your expense
okay will you do it will you do a
thought exercise with me
sure
you got two little ones right
i actually have three three how old are
they
uh 14
7 and 5. all right let's fast forward 18
months
and you've worked
maniacally you took a second job you had
somebody watch your kids on the weekends
because you started working you just
went bananas and paid this off
and you open your eyes
and you've got these three kids they're
18 months older
and you owe nobody anything
nothing
and you think about
sleep
and you think about being a little bit
less stressed of a mom
which allows you to get a little bit
closer to those kids because you're not
quite as radioactive and not quite you
don't have to spend quite as much time
numbing out on netflix and and whatever
else devices scrolling in front of you
just because you got to pass the day and
now you're out walking in the
neighborhood and you're smiling you see
what i'm saying you're talking about
changing your entire life
and that starts with you deciding i want
to be free
or
let's get some sushi
right
right why
tina how much are you investing in your
401k right now what percentage
6 is the company match that sucks you
should do 15. wouldn't that be better
you know what you can do when you don't
have payments you can invest more in
your 401k
right with a fully funded emergency
sushi until you're sick
we also have a roth too so i was like i
was starting to look into it but i
haven't gotten quite into it just yet
make a poster put it on the wall and say
i'm coming for you in the future
18 to 24 months from now when i'm out of
debt 30 months from now when i have that
fully funded emergency fund i'm going to
come back stronger than ever
15
and then we're gonna be saving for kids
college we're gonna be paying off the
house can you imagine what future tina's
gonna be like
she's gonna eat so much sushi she's
gonna be sick
so hang on the line austin will pick up
we're gonna gift you financial peace
university every dollar and some
homework for you go listen to episode 7
of my podcast the fine print all about
the dirty truth behind your credit score
it's you're going to be disgusted when
you find out all right we'll be right
back on the range show
[Music]
[Music]
hey we really value the input from
people who watch and listen to the
ramsay show it helps us know what's
important to you so we can deliver the
right content that will help you with
the questions and challenges you have
right now one way you can share your
thoughts with us is by answering a few
questions in a new survey we just
launched you can check out at
ramseysolutions.com
survey take you a few minutes and
there's a 500 visa gift card up for
grabs as a thank you for your time go to
ramseysolutions.com
survey and you can even answer it right
on your phone right so just visit
ramseysolutions.com
survey and help us out say nice things
about me and george all right let's go
to meredith in lexington kentucky what's
up meredith
hey how's it going excellent how are you
i'm i'm okay i'm sick today but i got um
i'm sorry opportunity to call in there
we go
uh okay so i have a it's a good problem
to have but um my boyfriend and i he's
more the financial guru but um
we are having a tough time figuring out
what to do with all this money that i've
saved that is just sitting in the bank
right now we're um debt free but we are
um i've got about 100 to 120 000 just
kind of sitting
sitting in my bank account and we don't
really know what
what to do with it before george answers
this
can i ask you why
your boyfriend
is speaking into your money decisions
here's why
my job is almost exclusively
when things happen to people that nobody
thinks is going to happen
that actually happens to a whole bunch
of people
and so you're giving six figures worth
of autonomy to somebody
who has no you can just walk at any time
so this is true why are you giving it
just buy a ring together so
do what he's listening to this right i
said we did just buy a ring together so
hopefully we'll be fiance in the near
future i'm assuming you guys have you've
combined bank accounts
no we have not we just cohabitate
okay but it sounds you kept saying we we
we all these decisions were a group
decision and so it made me think all
right the money's all entangled together
sure it's it's not it's not so meredith
i'm telling you this is talking about it
as like a future together yes i'm
telling you this because i love you i
would not do anything with him
at this point okay he does he does not
have a right to speak into your
financial situation and into your money
and i'm just telling you the number of
people we talked to
we were going to get married and so we
went ahead and did this we're going to
get married and we bought we bought a
ring we were engaged then we did this
and then he just walks that's totally
fair yes okay now he might be the
greatest guy in the world i'm not saying
he's a bad guy i'm just saying you are
the one exposed right now
sure right
okay so let's get to the financial part
so do you have any debt
no debt do you have an emergency fund
outside of this 120 or is this all the
cash to your name
that
uh yes well
i guess some of that would be i do also
have another 20 and a high yield savings
so okay let's call that your emergency
fund so let's say this other 120 is just
for fun
okay are you investing 15 of your income
yes the um my retirement account i
contribute five percent employer 10
so uh 15
and then
i
put in an additional 10
and like roth iras and voluntary 403 b
so you're saying 15 of your income is
going towards retirement in some way
shape or form okay great and where what
about the house situation
we
i just rent you're renting so so it
feels like the next plausible goal is to
get a house
for marriage sure
yes now we don't know what the future
holds for meredith and her boyfriend
so
you know i don't want you to make a
decision based on well he's moving into
this new house and it gets weird and
please please whatever you do do not put
his name on the mortgage and don't put
his name on the on the deed
if you're not married that is where
situations go sideways and hey real
quick george let's explain this here's
why um
if you put him on your deed and he's a
boyfriend and he decides to bail
the untangling of that is a mess
it's a disaster yeah if you're married
and one of you bails there's a legal
process to walk everybody out of that
and that's why we tell you you're
completely unexposed forget the morality
part forget the you go sunday school
i'm just saying purely it's not safe for
you because you have much less legal
protection see what i'm saying
yeah that makes sense one of the many
problems with cohabitation is you get
into a house and now he's paying you
half of the mortgage but he has no stake
in this house so he's not building any
asset now he's resentful and he walks
away and it just creates a a real
conundrum
and so that is another issue which one
of the reasons uh we're against that but
i'm gonna let you do you what i would do
with this money is just keep it in a
high-yield savings account because it
sounds like this decision whatever you
do with this is probably the next two
years we're not talking five years from
now right
as far as the home purchase
right yeah i'm thinking probably in the
next three or so years okay if it was
like three four five plus years i might
put it in an s p 500 index fund and let
it grow at maybe eight nine ten percent
but because of the time horizon uh i
don't want your money locked up in the
stock market and then it's down and all
of a sudden you're like oh my gosh we're
getting married now and the money's
locked up and it's down i don't want to
sell while the shares are down putting
in a high yield savings account is going
to give you that you know what one and a
half to two percent right now
it's nothing special but it's going to
keep your money safe keep it growing a
little bit and buy you time to make that
decision wisely so that's what i would
do if you need to make any other
upgrades you're like hey i'm driving a
beater car you can upgrade to a
reasonable car what's your income
uh 130 000. awesome meredith is crushing
it uh do you like what you drive right
now no issues good shape
oh i do i mean it's it is a 2010 honda
civic so i guess oh right on i got
another 900 60 000 miles on it so that's
the problem with the honda it's going to
go for it ever that's so good
man you've done really well meredith i'm
proud of you i know he's got to get that
guy and if he likes it he better put a
ring on it that's right
right all right let's run out to mark in
indianapolis hey marco right up against
the clock so get right to your question
absolutely i'm 60 years old i'm retiring
in
and we have two properties a home
property that's worth 300 000 no debt
another property is worth eight hundred
thousand and i have a hundred and
seventy thousand dollars of debt on it
i'm paying it off over the next four
years game plan to do that i have four
hundred thousand in cash sitting on the
sidelines
that i'm wondering if i should go ahead
and pay the 170 000 off
or just continue to stay with the plan i
have no other debt at all
and saving about 30 percent of what i
make today my wife and i so that's my
question stay with the plan to pay it
off over the next four years leave the
cash alone and use it for other
investments
we're going to convert some things out
of normal iras to roth so those are some
of my questions
mark if i'm in your shoes that mortgage
is gone today and we are celebrating
we're gonna burn it on the front lawn
have a party because we don't owe anyone
anything at 60 years old
and knowing you you could build that
thing back up to 400 000
pretty soon if you wanted to
absolutely and without that mortgage
payment you're gonna be able to do that
yeah the rate's so low is very it's one
of those mental things it's i think 2.75
and uh i'm making fairly good money on
my uh my cash this is kind of a wash so
um i just wanted to ask that question go
ahead and pay it off well the other
mental thing is going to bed knowing you
don't owe any 1.1 million dollars of
cash paid out
real estate assets oh yeah
absolutely you got the money to do it i
know it hurts because you're well this
money can make more money and this is a
low interest rate but at some point we
just got to stop playing the game and go
we're doing so well why are we even
hanging on to this thing and i think we
don't need this the most honest answer
george and i could both give you is
both of us in your exact situation would
pay the house off before the day is over
and both of us would love to have four
hundred thousand dollars just sitting
there going what do i do with this kind
of money
yeah uh that's a great problem i would
do that you'll have what 230 000 left
that you just can be you can be sad with
that money right and the millionaires we
talk to they just don't hang on to debt
they just get rid of it and use all
their future income to build wealth and
that's what you're going to be able to
do yeah people on uh george people on
instagram they love to hang on to debt
leverage the debt man love the debt you
can roll that hug the debt and then
yeah no
no thank you no i'll take freedom all
day long hey that's another hour in the
books here on the ramsay show stay with
us we'll be right back
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
so
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studios this is the
ramsey show where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life
your relationships
your money i'm john dolone joined by my
good friend george campbell and we are
taking your calls
live toll-free number eight eight two
five five two two five whatever you got
going on we're here for you triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to emily out
in marquette what is up emily
hi john how are you good how about you
i'm doing well thank you guys so much
for all you do and i've been following
the baby steps for a while and i'm
debt-free
i have
my six-month emergency fund saved and i
am investing so um i'm on the right
track i'm maxing out my
uh for my simple ira and my all of my
hsa all of that stuff so way to go my
question for you today is
since i have been doing all of that i
have been saving up because i have a
2012 ford tourist with about 145 000
miles on it
it's getting to be to the point where
i'm starting to look at a new to me car
and i've been looking a lot over the
last few months at both used cars and
new cars and many are similar in price
in fact some of the used cars are more
expensive than some of the smaller new
base model cars that i've been looking
at
one in particular i have found a dealer
that
will
give me a
new 2022 ford forester
subaru for around 27 000 and i have
about 26 000 in cash that i could pay
for that plus
a 4 000 trade in for my car which i've
also gotten priced out so my question is
i want to follow the baby steps um
should i buy a cheaper used car and save
the rest of the money or should i buy a
new car that will last me for a while
great question well first of all
congratulations on where you're at i
mean you have been busting it to get to
this point and i would say it's time for
emily to upgrade in car
thank you now to part two i still would
not buy a new car and it's not because
of the price
difference and of course you're always
gonna find a used car that could be more
expensive than a different new car
and uh you know my i grew up in a family
that was that was always like well you
got to have a nuke it's for safe and
reliable and you know there's no issues
with it and yet new cars break down all
the time and there's always there's
always something and the biggest reason
is because of depreciation because one
minute after you drive that thing off
the lot it loses
value
absolutely and that scares me so i want
someone else to take that initial hit
even if even i i bought my wife uh new
to us car
last year and
ran into a very similar situation
um and i ended up buying a i think it
was two years old
it was basically brand new i mean it was
in perfect pristine condition
but i just let somebody else pay that
five thousand dollars of depreciation
okay and i should take it so
also there is another car okay oh i'm
sorry go ahead i was gonna tell you i'll
also tell you behind closed doors when
it's me and dave and george and rachel
and we're debating this there is some
discussion about this like if it's if
it's same as cash i mean if it if it's
six and a half dozen another does it
really matter like so we're debating
this behind closed doors so we're
nobody's gonna be mad at you right um
we're just telling you what george and i
would do
what we have done with our own money in
our own homes right but the principle is
until you are a net worth millionaire
it's not worth taking the hit on
depreciation with a new car if you got a
million bucks you can you can flush
thousand bucks down so after one minute
the research shows that it loses nine to
eleven percent of its value and in the
first year is when it loses the most it
can be worth about twenty percent less
obviously that varies depending on what
car you buy or this crazy market this
market yeah everyone's like well george
you're an idiot because used cars are
more expensive than they yes of course
there's this weird one little blip on
the entire timeline guys that we can
focus in on yeah so emily i would also
look at maybe not going to a dealership
and seeing what you can find privately
and do a pre-purchase inspection on that
and selling your other car privately to
get more than trade-in value because
they're gonna they're gonna give you you
know pennies on the dollar versus what
you could get in the marketplace and you
had one more question emily what was it
right
oh that was it kind of went along with
what you said there was a dealer that
has a two-year-old forester for right
around just under the same price as the
new one um but it's a used car it has
about 20 000 miles on it
but it's basically new and um they also
would be willing to pay for my trade in
there but um you kind of just answered
that question yeah i mean it may if
they're really giving you a great deal
because of the trade-in i would run the
numbers on it but check the kelly blue
book value of your current car and if
it's worth a 7k and they're giving you a
2k discount and the trading is 4k i
would rather you just go sell it
privately now the one of the caveats is
we don't know what the dealership is
going to do when you tell them oh by the
way i'm paying cash and they go oh well
that discount was only if you were
financing with us so we're not going to
give it to you for 27.
i can't tell you and by the way you have
to get the warranty it's 5 000 for the
warranty and you'd be stupid not to get
that and they're going to sit there and
waste three hours of your time and your
time is worth more than that emily so
don't fall for their games look at that
contract you sign make sure it's just
sales tax and a small doc fee anything
else is highway robbery and run away
from that dealership because they are
not trustworthy people and i'll i'll say
this george
i have to decide i don't say side with
emily i don't think she don't think she
has a side
so if i'm looking at two cars
and the 20
20 car is 25 000
and the 2022 car is 25 000
all cost considered if if if that if we
are in a glitch of the matrix where it's
not depreciating it's not falling 15 20
when i drive it off the lot
does it make sense then to go ahead and
say okay i'll just buy the new one i
mean does it matter at that point one
thing we're not taking into
consideration is that used car has
always has already taken its hit and
depreciation that new car hasn't right
okay so so actually you think i might
buy this car for 25 grand it's actually
worth 23. and it's gonna appreciate a
slower rate than that new car wheel
because one year from now that used car
could be worth 24 that new car is now
worth way less so that's a possibility
depending on the type of car and
depreciation rates in this crazy market
but i still think when it comes to that
wisdom of million dollar net worth get
you a new car
i like that because it slows us down and
makes us make better decisions because
most people we just see the shiny toys
and cars are now we're seeing average
car payments 733 average car is 48 000.
i'm like this is madness
it's just a hunk of metal on wheels dude
[Music]
so stop the insanity and buy cars we can
afford in cash that is the key i love it
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm john delonie
joined by george campbell we're taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go out to
george in gainesville florida what's up
brother george
hey how you guys doing thank you for
taking my call you got it man what's up
hey so i just found out that i'm being
sued
from a debt collector
and i just have no idea how to approach
any of this there's already a hearing
date for next month on the 11th
um i'm just pretty scared i'm not gonna
lie i know it's not gonna be the end of
the world but i just don't know what to
do
that's pr
well i'll let george walk you through
the letters it's probably not a true
hearing date but
why
why aren't you paying off your debts
well so that was about
the best buy credit card from about two
and a half years ago probably
um why didn't you pay it off
say it again why didn't you pay it off
um just
straight up i just couldn't afford it
i i'm 24 now i pretty much had to grow
up on my own at the age of 18 so
everything's been on my own expense
almost kind of paycheck to paycheck
since then okay
and i was making the minimum payments
every month
and then cobra kind of hit and my hours
were affected a lot
um i made eight thousand dollars last
year all of last year
um and i was still able to make it
paying my rent and utility bills but i
just
that was it i couldn't really pay any of
my credit card stuff and what other debt
do you ask them
uh just so i have the credit card debt
i have student loan debt
and car debt okay hey we're gonna get
into your question okay
but but
like can we just pretend you and me and
george are sitting on a table having
some nachos just talking so i can be
direct with you
yeah why are you making 8 000 in one
calendar year
during one of the hottest job markets in
the history of this country
yeah i just um
i didn't have a car until
this
past february
and um i just to be honest with you i
just couldn't find music transportation
so i stuck i was looking at publix for
about five years i don't think george i
don't think i believe that
because i've had seasons in my life
where i have to ride my bike to work i
was married with a kid but my truck
broke
like you figure it out when you find
yourself up against the wall
yeah
like what what's what's the hold up man
you're worth more than eight thousand
dollars
you're worth five times that much
now i'm actually starting uh january
this past january i just started working
full-time for my church
um so that this is the first time and so
what do you make now
i make um 17.50 an hour
okay
well
are you done making excuses because we
can't help you until you're ready to
clear this up man
yeah i mean yeah yeah okay the civil
suit like you mentioned is not the end
of the world but we do have to get it in
writing so i need you to actually well
let's tell what happened here so a
company bought
bad debt for pennies on the dollar from
best buy okay they sold you owed them
how much how much was the original debt
i don't know what the original but the
the amount they have on all the papers
is 2700 okay so you probably owed 1500
bucks they sold it for 500 and then
they've tacked on a whole bunch of fees
and interest and
they say send you a letter and say give
us 2700
that's what they're doing okay so
they've bought this debt for way less
than 2700 bucks
and now their goal is to see how much
they can extract from you
okay yeah
so george starting today
number one debt is off the table do you
have any more credit cards that are open
no okay we're not going to touch debt
ever again
yeah agree with that
yeah clearly it's not your friend
it's burnt you too many times in the
past so going forward we need to
actually communicate and take our head
out of the sand and go all right this
sucks i don't like where i'm at but i'm
going to communicate openly and honestly
with this debt collector and say i need
this in writing i need you to confirm
the debt confirm the amounts the age of
the debt and if they can't produce that
then they they have to throw it out
legally but they probably will say here
it is best buy here's the purchases you
made here's much debt here's the fees
and then we go okay this sucks and now i
have to go figure out a way to pay for
this or do you have five hundred dollars
no it's 2700 you have 1500 bucks
cash
what kind of car do you drive
i have a 2014 kia forte okay okay what's
the loan on that
um it was about
9.99
out the door
yeah 9900 and i paid 4 000
down payment so you have 6k on the loan
a little bit under 5 probably now okay
so we're going to list all these debts
smallest to largest you got to deal with
this one in collections first because
the law is involved this is an ankle
biter
but beyond that if they're willing to
settle let's say 1500 bucks that's great
and they may go all right we're going to
drop the hearing date this guy is
actually willing to pay us some money
yeah if you call them and say i'll give
you 1 500 today that's what i've got or
i've got 980 dollars that's probably
gonna be too too much of a cut for them
but
i got 980 bucks i got cash i'll do it
right now you guys send me a contract in
writing that says this will guarantee
this and i will get you paid under no
circumstances do you give them access to
your checking account they'll say i'll
do it but you got to give me your
checking account number no way
if they call them and ask them if they
will settle this thing my friend anthony
o'neil used to work collections and he
said it's best to call at the very end
of the month but you may have a hearing
date before that so um but call them and
just say i'll give you this much i'll
give you 25 i'll give you 50 i got cash
and i'm gonna make this thing happen
okay
and then go ahead george no i mean
that's this is the strategy here there's
no shortcut george we just have to pay
off our debts that we went into and
learn from the mistakes so what do you
do for the church george
i work for facilities so just
maintaining the church in a general
sense what are your hours
i work for i'm a full-time so i work 40
hours a week now what are your hours
eight to five
oh seven to three monday through friday
seven to three how old are you
24 24. you've had a rough go of it huh
childhood was hard
yeah okay
listen to me super carefully
you're at a crossroads
right now
and i spent my career working with young
people okay
i've i'm looking directly at you
you're at a crossroads right now and you
have an opportunity to change everything
your family tree changed the lives of
grandkids you've never met yet
you have an opportunity to work like a
maniac for the next 36 months
when you get off your job at three you
go directly to another job and you get
done with that job you're gonna deliver
pizzas or drive uber until 12 o'clock at
night you're gonna get up next morning
do it again
and you're going to get yourself
something you've never had which is
financial margin
and then you're going to start doing
things you've never done before like
sleep the whole night
and be able to pay your rent and not
worry about it
be able to take somebody out on a date
and just pay for it not worry about it
does it sound good
yeah it's a different life but i also
tell you this
if you just park it you get done at
three o'clock and you go home and play
video games you're going to find
yourself right back where we were
that's my promise to you i've just met
too many guys in your situation you've
got a magic moment here dude but it's
going to take you grinding and working
grinding and working writing working so
here's the deal george and i are gonna
are gonna
shoot you out of this thing with jet
fuel okay i'm gonna give you a year of
uh ramsay plus i'm gonna send you a copy
of total money makeover and i'm gonna
send you the every dollar app for a year
just taken away every excuse you have
and i want you to watch these videos and
if you've got some buddies that would
watch them with you that'd be even
better
is that fair
yeah thank you thank you very much could
you go through it with some people at
the church and say hey who wants to do
financial peace university with me
because you can't do this stuff alone
you got to have people in your corner
yeah they didn't make a girlfriend to do
with me perfect somebody and get some
men in your life
that are 5 and 10 and 15 years ahead of
you will you do
that yeah you cannot walk this thing
alone but brother you are at a
crossroads and i can't wait to hear from
you
in three or four years
when you owe nobody anything
you're getting married you've got a
full-time job making 80 000 a year
you're out of school whatever the thing
is man
you can do anything
but you gotta start
go make it happen we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever noticed that when you
commit to change in one area of your
life it's easier to make progress in the
other areas
i've met thousands of people on their
journey to building wealth who
accomplished other amazing things along
the way like losing 50 pounds finding a
career they love overcoming stress and
anxiety healing their marriage what
seems impossible becomes possible when
you have a smart plan and you turn up
the focus and intensity on your goals
that's why we're bringing smart
conference to dallas texas on sept on
saturday october 22nd smart conference
is the one day event where we help you
build momentum in all areas of your life
whether you're busy searching for a new
job paying off your debts with gazelle
intensity or taking the first step to
finally understanding why you feel
anxious all the time while you're lonely
this event will give you a plan and
encouragement you need to keep going
ramsay personalities including rachel
cruz myself ken coleman george campbell
will join dave ramsey on stage to give
you a smart plan for your money
relationships personal growth and career
join us live in person on october 22nd
to get your passes before they sell out
visit
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats
today let's go out to nikita in kansas
city what's up nikita
hi can you hear me okay absolutely
what's up
perfect thank you so much for taking my
call today you got it excited
so um my question for you is um what's
essentially happened is i missed a
rollover deadline at work and so now i
have a couple options in front of me
for my
retirement account
and
so what we what we have what we're
working with here is um other than a
home loan we have a vehicle loan and
then student loans
um thanks to you guys
we've knocked out like 70 000 worth of
debt already awesome um
and so my
my next i guess my next question is i
want to
cash out
my
the money that is
at hand
um to help pay
that essentially would pay off my car
loan entirely and then put a good chunk
towards my student loans um however i
don't know if that is
the most wise decision and so that's why
i was hoping for a little bit of
guidance yeah that is a lot a lot less
awesome to cash out your retirement
early i mean you sound young how old are
you
i'm 32. okay a lot less awesome yeah you
are going to take a giant hit if you
cash this money out right so i would not
there's penalties fees your income tax i
would not do this i want you to use
future income i've already paid 70 grand
off using your own income right
yeah so how much longer do we have are
you tired why why are you doing this
well no i just um we're at a point to
where
because pulling it out would essentially
mean being able to get rid of almost all
of it also means you can't retire
well i mean
you're right there is there's that and
you're gonna take some money you earned
and give a big chunk of it to the
government just for fun just for fun
well
i know i don't like to okay how much
debt is left i think some math will help
you feel confident in this plan what's
on the car line
the car loan is 18 000 and student loans
we paid that down quite a bit and then
student loans is my highest one that one
was 39. okay what's your household
income
um we are at about 95 000. how long did
it take you to pay off 70.
um
it took us
i'd say about five years but this last
year with colbit as a nurse
i was able to make some
i had opportunity at better incomes with
overtime and being short staffed so i
took advantage of
those opportunities and um so actually
this last year is when we've been able
to pay the most off have you been
investing this whole time you've been
trying to pay off debt
yeah yeah i mean i've been invested
ever i mean are i only have four percent
and they match up to four percent
um so that's all i've been doing up to
this point is just the bare minimum
until um well that makes more sense
because five years to pay off 70 grand
with your income sucks doesn't it
yeah yeah it does which is why you're
tired
but it's so great i'm going to ask you
to do something crazy nikita i'm going
to ask you to stop investing until your
debt is paid off and you have a fully
funded emergency fund
okay how much money do you have in the
bank um in savings we have
um 23 000 plus them okay i'm going to
tell you to do something even crazier
take 18 of that and pay off the car loan
today
you know what that does though hear me
out what does that do it frees up your
car payment doesn't it
right and what if you pause investing
what's that four percent amount to
a hundred a few hundred bucks at least
at least yeah okay now we have a car
payment and a few hundred bucks and
we're gonna work a side hustle now we're
going oh my gosh we just have 39 000 of
student loans in front of us that we're
going to crush in the next
14 months 16 months you're a nurse you
can work like a maniac for i heard those
are in high demand john that's the rumor
but nikita do you see what we're doing
here you're not making enough progress
and therefore you're looking to
shortcuts but the reason you're not
making progress is because you're doing
17 things at once and not following the
plan all in you're holding a box of
bandages and you're bleeding out
yeah
don't do that
don't do that okay
you've got a false security blanket of
that of that savings account it feels so
safe
and you're not looking at the other side
of the risk leverage you owe a whole
bunch of people money i mean you owe
people a whole bunch of money
so that money that you're holding for
them isn't yours even though it feels
like it is
that's true that's a fantastic way to
just give them their money so they can
go on with their day and you can be free
just
get just do it and be done with it how
much longer do you want to be in pain i
would want it to be the shortest amount
of time possible right you're a nurse
it's like you have the syringe in your
arm for five years because you have
instead of just going let's get it over
with this is gonna hurt but we're gonna
pay off the freaking car today we're
gonna have money left over in the bank
we're gonna go down to a thousand
dollars the student loan is gonna be our
worst enemy we're gonna put it on the
wall and throw darts at it
and soon enough you're gonna have no
debt no payments in the world with a
fantastic income and you're gonna be
back to investing not a measly four
percent but fifteen percent
over triple that yes that is the
ultimate goal and you're gonna come back
with it with fury and rage with this
investment account nobody screws with
nikita when she gets angry right oh
right i mean stop by stop buying
creditors nice things that's what you're
doing right
it's true okay
that's fantastic sallie mae is over here
going to hawaii nikita needs to go to
hawaii
i do you work too hard to feel this
broke yes you've worked so hard i think
like and i say this with all due respect
thank you for your service like if you
and your team have kept this thing
running right it's been it's been a
crazy couple of years but i do love my
job so i'm thankful i have one well
those of you those of us who are clumsy
and or accident-prone and or who have
small kids we are grateful too because
we have visited you often in the last
few years and nikita's giving herself a
raise today john because she's paying
off that car loan look at that what's
that car payment what is that car
payment
um i think about 304 bucks a month so
and add that to the four percent
investing that you're going to pause and
add that to the overtime you're going to
do and add that to getting on a budget
and cutting some expenses and the fancy
gym membership and the sushi nights out
we're just doing this for a short time
so that we can have long-term freedom
right hey what's your what's your hourly
rate
um well see and that's the other hard
part is um so my flat rate is
approximately 30 an hour okay can we can
we do this math this way
let's just let's just do easy math here
we're up against the clock
let's say 30 an hour and that that car
payment is is 340 bucks a month
so yeah
is that about 11 hours a month
you're buying basically a day and a half
of your life back
i would love to not have to work so much
okay no you're right
who knew money could buy freedom that's
amazing yeah
these are the words i needed to hear so
now your husband's going to tell you
that you're crazy we're not getting rid
of this
savings account
yes we're on the road right now we've
been playing out a lot of different
scenarios and that's why i was like we
just need to call and ask and see what
it is they would tell us to do and
that's what will
that's what our next step will be hey if
you hate it if you hate this plan you
can go back into debt later but right
now try it off if you have to you can
send me and george 340 bucks a month
just to just to appease your soul we're
happy to take it but i'd love to see
that go into your savings account thanks
for the call we'll be cheering you on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is
ephesians 4 2.
be completely humble and gentle be
patient
bearing with one another in love
that's good stuff
the great and mighty will ferrell says
before you marry a person you should
first make them use a computer with slow
internet to see who they really are
oh that's a good one that's fantastic
true words have never been spoken
exactly i think part of marriage
counseling should be sitting in front of
a dial-up connection speaking of that
ephesians bible verse about humility
will ferrell's family does not think
he's funny
oh man i mean if that's not humbling i
don't know what it is what's like
did i tell you about the
argument i got with my son the other day
no
um we're going back and forth about
something that morphed into dead you're
not famous and i was like i'm for sure
famous and he said that you're not and
he was 100 right but i found myself
arguing with a 12 year old which is
always a disaster and
i
then was trying to like bring in my old
career and i was like hey i was the
chief student affairs officer at a
billion dollar university i was huge and
he goes dad you're
you're just a youtuber man oh
sick but do you drive a dodge stratus
but do i jaw drive a dodge stratus
bringing it back full circle with will
ferrell oh that's good i drive it dodged
a lot man all right let's go to charlie
in atlanta what's up charlie
how are you doing we're rocking out to
the break of down my brother what's up
awesome um so yeah me and my girlfriend
i'm 20 my girlfriend's 18. over the past
two and a half months our social media
accounts have gained a little over 3
million followers
we made 20 000 the first month 28 000
the second month
and our managers and other content
creators are saying that over the next
12 months we should be expected to make
around 30 to 50 000 each month so my
question is what to do um with this new
blessing and this new money what do you
what's in your social media account
uh it's basically just me and my
girlfriend make vlogs and stuff like
that
wow i mean me and john will do that and
it will get zero dollars so good for you
man we make a grand total of zero
dollars from all our effort okay so hold
on what makes your videos special
uh
we we incorporate uh faith into
everything um so you know i i don't
i mean we take pride in our videos and
we like to share the gospel and uh put
that first so i'm assuming that other
than just being funny i guess wow way to
go man all right so before george gets
you into what you're gonna do with this
money let me caution you okay
all righty the
internet's world and the management
world and
it is all about optimism
you're probably gonna make this much
dude you're probably there's a reality
to it all okay and there's an ebb and
flow to it i had something spin up the
other day on tick tock that i didn't
know how to log into tick tock and it
got millions of views and then my
instagram got followed
and then a couple days later i was back
to regular old just a youtuber just
being a youtuber right so
this thing goes in waves and it goes up
and down
hang on to your hats don't start
living above your means on prom on on
like yeah i think by the end of this
month you're gonna be making make sure
you got money in the bank before you do
anything is that cool right right for
sure yeah we've seen
social media come and go and every vine
star is now going oh my gosh that was my
livelihood and it's gone and youtube
changed their policy on monetization and
now i lost my career and instagram
changed their algorithm and now no one's
seeing my content and i'm making three
thousand dollars a month and so you can
use this money very wisely
to retire early if you want to or you
can increase your lifestyle and it can
be gone and all of a sudden you're back
to square one
it sounds like you want to do the first
one you want to use this wisely
for sure and you're super young man do
you have your whole life ahead of you so
do you have any debt i hope not at this
age
no i'm not i'm actually still in college
so um i don't have any debt i don't have
a house i have no payments at all cash
flow in college
it's paid for right right
yes everything paid for um i've been
blessed my parents put money away so how
much money do you have in the bank
uh right now we have about 30 000. okay
you keep saying we are you saying you
and your girlfriend have the same bank
account yeah
so
we
technically have an llc together good
it's like a business account essentially
right so so everything is essentially in
a business account we haven't taken any
cut at all have you all had a sat with
an attorney to write up draw outs with
drawdowns how are you going to pay
yourself okay so you'll have a salary
every month now
uh we we actually just met with them
this morning so um we we are working
towards that now so is it going to be a
percentage basis of the total growth of
what you're making or the net of what
you're drinking okay
are you working with a investment
professional yet
i'm we are not okay
well outside of having your emergency
fund you have no debt i want you to
graduate from college and make that a
priority because we don't know what the
future holds we don't know what three
years from now looks like and if that's
cash flow do you have an emergency fund
then we can begin investing 15 of our
income and the rest i would save up and
try to pay cash for a house with this
kind of income that's gonna just
catapult you in your financial journey
to have a paid for house in your early
twenties
gotcha and i would get something
reasonable and same with a car you have
a decent car right now
yeah i got it i mean it's brand new i
got it for my third year in college and
my parents bought me a new truck before
i went to college and they paid for it
as a gift yeah
yeah mighty kind of them so you're good
in that department which means you don't
have a lot of expenses i imagine
right no no expenses other than cherish
it while that exists because adulthood
will come for you soon and you'll be
like i gotta pay for my health insurance
now oh my gosh and so the more money you
have the more of a financial foundation
you have and so i would live on way less
than you make continue living how you've
been living as a broke college kid and
you're going to be just fine and you can
go to ramseysolutions.com and start to
build your board of directors so to
speak
get an investment professional get a tax
professional because you're probably
going to have a huge tax exempt be the
one to get get first
and you got to be setting money aside
for that so work with a great tax
professional you're probably going to
work with a great real estate
professional we have all of that
insurance professionals so go to
ramseysolutions.com click on trusted
pros and start to interview these people
in your area and assemble this dream
team of how are we going to use this
money wisely how are we going to be good
stewards of what god has entrusted us
with this amazing platform
right awesome is that cool can i give
you one more piece of wisdom okay
charlie
for sure
it could happen
y'all break up
right yeah and so within within the next
couple months we'll be engaged so and
and you could still break up and here's
what i'm telling you that i want y'all
to have the hard conversations y'all are
business partners now i'm really glad to
hear y'all getting llc that was the note
i'd written here is y'all are now in a
hot at a business making a lot of money
as a 20 year old and 18 year old who are
dating right and that's a lot of
feelings and a lot of emotions and a lot
of
supercharged stuff and a lucrative
business and that is just a recipe for a
bonfire okay
so have the hard conversations are we
going to keep doing this if when how are
we going to do this when we get in a
fight how are we going to do this when
we are trying to get married too how are
we gonna do like have those
conversations and don't get married
because you have a cool business when
you're 20.
get married because she's the right
person for you long term is that fair
fair cool well congratulations man way
to go dude that's awesome um
pretty impressive i know got way more
instagram followers than we do george i
guess it's time for us to start our
influencer instagram now john
just me and you vlogging on the road
maybe you could teach me how to do like
you know the man stuff i never learned
you know like we go hunting you show me
how to mow lawns change tires i think
that'd be a huge hit
check oil
just kidding i don't have that jokes on
you
oh yeah just got rid of that one last
thing powered car one more check on the
on the man card there you don't need to
worry about that
you're welcome john and then i'll teach
you how to uh what's something you're
not good at you're good at everything
i'm pretty good
you can teach me how to your hair
the time you see like it's perfect
that's not a talent
i was hoping for something way better
than your hair
i appreciate it you could teach me all
of your fast food hacks that's true but
i've we went to chick-fil-a the other
day together in the drive-through and it
took 111 minutes well can i tell you
john's order before we uh go to break
here
[Laughter]
14 000 chicken tenders for protein
that's it
that's all he ordered
and george
and i got a kids meal
you did that's how i keep my childlike
physique john hey we i would like to
thank all the guys in the booth for
keeping us going i like to thank you
george good show today fun times and i'd
like to thank everybody listening listen
have a good weekend be kind to one
another
find ways you can have joy in your life
and if you if it's time to make the
decision to make everything different
we're here for you we'll be back soon on
the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500
visa gift card no purchase necessary
take the survey at ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
you